nice to meet you
um so today we're talking about that we
i think abortion is a cop-out you mean
like it's just like uh it's like oh i
forgot i just now i can just get an
abortion i think i think most women make
poor decisions
and they're not being careful
and what was supposed to be a last
resort is now becoming a cop-out for
poor decisions but there's so but it's
so broad there's so many different types
of abortions okay so like what are you
defining as an abortion do you do is
plan b an abortion yes or no what what
say you okay so i don't i don't have an
opinion on plan b because i i honestly
don't know enough about plan b
so i'm so broad i'm talking about the
data that i'm talking about was taken
from abortion centers so it's not it's
not including plan b i'm saying i'm
saying it's not like it's such a broad
here all i know i was telling your
friend over here is that i'm a father of
two daughters
and you know you know what you know what
my opinion should be
my opinion should be shut the [ __ ] up
brandon
but i can have a voice because i'm a
girl right of course sir what
i don't even i'm saying for me my dog
like i'm if i sit around the dinner
table i'm not allowed i shouldn't have
an opinion
really i think men should have an
opinion it's their kid this is why we
have a lack of masculinity in society
guys stop letting women tell you that
you can't have an opinion because you're
a man if anything we should listen to
men we should listen to men we're
emotional we get on our period once a
month we're crazy we are nuts and men
don't have that so if you don't go to
men for logic what what do we have in a
society and we our society is so
brainwashed that we have convinced men
that they can't have an opinion
on
a child that is half theirs that they
helped make
you don't think okay you don't think
your daughters you you would rather
teach them to be careful with who they
sleep with well no but you know what i
am doing i'm i'm not i'm not hiding
meaning that i don't we're open at every
we're open like where your parents open
with you at the table like were you
afraid were you able to say anything
will you be able to ask them anything
and would they honestly give you the
answers yeah
well that's good because that's how
that's our approach our approach is like
you know what this is this is what an
iud is this is you know where you know
have your guy wear a condom go on the
pill because you know what there's some
parents that don't talk about the pill
okay and they're like god forbid i don't
want to talk about the pill because you
know i don't think my kid is sexually
active when in reality they could be
teen pregnancies are actually dropping
and the majority of abortions are
actually over the age of 21. so i just
think if you're getting an abortion if
you're getting an abortion over the age
of 21 you you know the reproductive
you know and i think
it's like too old i respect your opinion
i respect his opinion and his opinion i
respect everybody's opinion
so that's that's what mine so but i'm
not judging anybody so if you believe
that but everybody should be able to
choose what they want to do
okay so today we're talking about
abortion yeah so my my statement is that
in the majority of casein cases abortion
is a cop-out okay i'm from new york what
do you mean about a cop out like what
does that what does that mean
so basically it it means that you made a
poor choice and you don't want to deal
with the consequences okay i disagree i
think that having and deciding to have
an abortion is actually a choice of
power and courage and you're
acting over your body and your decision
and being a parent deciding to be a
parent and to be a mother is such a
great deal then forcing a kid to grow up
when you don't have the economical or
mental issues and reasons to like birth
and like carry a child i think it like
it doesn't make any sense so the
misconception is that people that are
poorer are more likely to get abortions
only eight percent of women below the
poverty line are getting abortions where
women that make forty seven thousand
dollars per year or more one out of
three get abortion so it's not really an
economic issue yeah but it doesn't have
to do with economic it has to do with
your mental health if you don't want to
have a child then you shouldn't bring a
child into the world but don't you think
they should be more careful when they're
having sex then
like yeah but accidents happen and that
doesn't mean that you have to like have
a child because i think it's worse for
you to have it than to have an abortion
because it doesn't make any sense so the
problem is 40 of women that have
abortions they've had two or more
already so it's not necessarily like the
majority of women and they don't track
out of the 60 who get them in the future
no no i don't think like i don't think
that's accurate and like also from
planned parenthood and looking about
like person like yeah that might be
accurate but at the same time it's a
personal decision so like every woman
has to make a choice over their body
because it's their body and it has
nothing to do with like whether society
says it has to do or whether it happens
or not happens and the fact that
abortion is now being like real versus
weight is being overruled in new york is
such a sad thing that happened and it
makes you think like oh my god if this
is happening then what happens to my
rights then what happens to me
i have the right to be abstinent yeah i
think you have you have the right to not
go through an abortion and carry for the
pregnancy at the same time another woman
has a right to not carry and go on with
it okay so here's here's my question do
you think abortion should be legal up to
birth
um you said my body my choice so when i
think of my body my choice like even the
week before i give birth it's still my
body my choice and this is the question
they can't answer if it's my body my
choice then stand on that logic abortion
should be legal up to birth stand on it
or don't have the argument at
all to a state why can't you just well
that's how the us government works is
you you have different laws in every
state okay let's go to the right right
so again less than one percent of
abortion so but this is but so this is
this is my channel we talk about we
don't talk about exceptions we're
talking about the rule so you don't talk
about acceptance we're talking because
this is what people often will try to
make an argument using the exception
when we're talking about the rule i'm
i'm asking you to like respectfully
we're not we're not talking about that
exception
okay no because you're part of it i
don't get how you can come here and not
want to talk about the exception because
99 of abortions are due are not in the
case of grapes so we're talking about
the 99 percent
i have nothing to offer i have nothing
that's the argument i'm making for the
99 of abortions that are not great it is
a cop-out because they made poor
decisions
what do you think about with
you don't you think that grapes so great
youtube what do you think then i'm
asking what is your opinion on great and
yeah because i think you're again you're
trying to make an argument i think
you're trying to make an argument for
like the exception rather than the rule
and so this because because because it's
less than one percent of the case
but this is what because i'm not talking
about that i could see a potential
policy for exceptions but i'm talking
about the rule and the i would say okay
little things
they don't even exist
they don't what do they not exist like
it's a con it's a human concept
construct that you're this the rule and
the exception it's still part of it do
you not see what i'm saying
but i but this is this is what i'm
talking about 90 the nine this is the
argument i'm making i i know but this is
this is you can do that on your channel
on my channel we're talking about the 99
of abortion that that are outside of
that case
you'll have you'll have like
most people here are going to talk about
that one percent yeah and i don't think
it's a good argument that's that's the
thing you can't even argue about it so
it clearly is a good argument because
you're done for you don't know what to
say because i i have an opinion on it
but we're not talking i wouldn't say i
wouldn't i would i wouldn't i wouldn't
say it so i wouldn't say
okay i i can do what i want on my
channel
like
okay but i'm here this is a job so again
like you're coming to my job and saying
this is you need to talk about what i
want on your channel
no i will it's just
okay would you okay so would you agree
that the 99 percent of cases it's a
cop-out outside of not at all not this
isn't i don't think you're going to
change many people's lives in the uk
coming here you're it's actually
offending many people okay that's that's
okay yeah no it is i think how many
people have all passed that's why we
came over here
i was like what is on here like what are
you doing sorry no offense to you like
you're allowed to have your own choice
but we were in shock that's why we came
over because it's ridiculous i don't
it's crazy that you're kind of
brainwashed almost like
i don't think you're brainwashed because
you have your opinion so it's a little
bit offensive when you say that i'm
brainwashed because i disagree with you
because
look i don't i don't think you're
brainwashed i think you just have your
opponent i think in the respect that
you're saying ignore that i think that's
why i think that ignore that exception
that's what that's made us think the
argument i'm making isn't in the cases
of great that's not the argument i'm
saying in 99 percent of cases it is a
cop-out plus okay that's true for
offending dude
it's okay it's okay